thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an
electrifying wild ride with Stevo we've
got arguably the king of EDM electronic
dance music Steve Aoki and wow was he
candid I went ahead and asked about the
celebrity DJs and like how easy is it to
pretend to be DJing and you're really
not DJing like dude he is the coolest he
came with the goods he served up the
juice and man this one is humongous so
strap on your seat belts and let's get
into it
all right
and uh we're good to go yeah
ladies and gentlemen Steve Aoki yeah now
you've met Scott Randolph sir you've met
Vinnie what's up too nice to meet you
um man off to a crazy start
um we show up setting up the podcast and
someone comes over to the bus and says
Steve's about to get into a cold plunge
and he wants to know if if you want to
join him
like how am I going to say no to that
that's what it takes to get you in a
cold plunge nowadays
nowadays I'm not surprised you didn't do
it I I you haven't done it yet I was
like Wow Stevo hasn't done a cold plunge
out of all the crazy [__] you've done
like this is awesome I gotta do the
first one with you you know I mean I've
jumped into cold water for sure yeah I
mean one of the first things I ever did
way back in the day was extreme ice
skating where I uh went out on a frozen
River it's skating
and a two-tier until I fell through the
ice
um but yeah that's five minutes
by the end of that five minutes I was
not we did the whole five I did the
whole five dude you wouldn't let me yeah
real naked joke over here yes
I feel you try to like slide out towards
him like nah man you're coming back in I
mean I don't understand what how that
can be good for you well how do you feel
now I feel great now now
yeah uh not on a regular basis you do
five minutes yeah it would be like four
or five minutes I feel like at some
point is the diminishing returns yeah
but you know I actually I don't really
do it for like the inflammation you know
which is a big reason why you should do
it uh the muscle inflammation all that
stuff but I do it just for my the chaos
in my mind and how to control that and
find calm in it and and um and then
obviously there's like you know your
mitochondria's [__] movie your cells
are going crazy you're you're your
immune system is getting boosted all of
this stuff inside cold plunges are
having a moment where a lot of people
are broadcasting to the world that
they're so good for you
I mean I'm a Believer in the in extreme
coal exposure also extreme heat exposure
so like just just saunas on a regular
basis I think sauna is even better than
than that cold punch as far as health
benefits okay do you have a sauna at
your house too dude we came out of this
we're roasting we're like basically
turkeys in the oven yeah we were
roasting
but yeah man that's sad it's just great
man I really appreciate how uh you know
like just ready to go you were as soon
as we met like oh let's do this let's do
that well you're Stevo man I mean I've
been watching you do the crazy [__] like
on TV forever so I'm like I gotta I
gotta get to your level you know at
least a little bit I love that I love
that you got a huge foam pit in the
house we both did gainers off of the
platform into the foam pit
they hit the skateboard ramp that
they didn't snap again we did the Aoki
jumps in the studio I'm so surprised
that out of all those Polaroids on the
wall that I'm the only one you're the
only one yeah and no one has to do it
yeah yeah a bunch of [__]
yeah dude how old are you 45 45 okay I'm
uh soon to be 49. well yeah you're aging
a lot better than I am man and I'm not
aging terribly
but uh you're doing really what's it
like to be at the last year of your 40s
because 50 sounds so old you know what I
mean like and sporties is like okay yeah
it's like old but it's not old
I'm like five years from now so I'm
trying to savor every single [__] day
I have I don't want to be [__] 50
that's too [__] scary so that's a
light man I mean dude I've got this tour
that I was telling you about and I come
out on stage I say you know I don't
expect you guys to know this but I'm in
a really bad situation I'm Stevo in my
40s and like it gets a laugh but if I
were to do the same line and say I'm
Stevo in my 50s then it stops being
funny
it just it's different yeah it hits
different and so I'm wrapping up this
tour and my next tour is uh the whole
show is gonna be like a kind of an
examination of how I'm confronting
middle age yeah and and being becoming
actually old right I'm lashing out at
father time like obviously your body
it it's different like it heals
differently you feel that or it's not
the same as it used to be I definitely
need to retire from doing back flips
okay even that Gainer we just did in
your house I came up so short and just
landed on my face that's the great thing
about the phone
so but uh but hey man we get older and
that's what happens are your Aoki jumps
getting lower uh I don't know I your
jump was pretty high 49. uh well thanks
man 48 at the moment
is that ice bath dude yeah the ice bath
yeah I mean you might need to
incorporate some of that I mean if you
you know for like just limberness and
like you know do you do yoga yeah I mean
not I do it like what I kind of do like
the 10 minute yoga before I work out
okay so it's more like stretch that
sounds that sounds good for me man I I'm
terrified of yoga yeah why it's just
like
and whenever I've done it I I've found
the experience to be so miserable that I
just can't stand doing it I dread the
idea of because you can't stretch well
or you can't yeah I just uh I can't
stretch or I mean I don't know you've
done it with me I hate it I hate it you
don't like it either I hate it so much
that I'm like so pissed off at the
teacher while we're doing it but like I
realize it's my fault that I think I did
it because 100 years
sucks so bad and one step worse is that
everything about the the
miserable experience is my body crying
out that it needs me to do yoga it's
like me not doing yoga because I don't
like the experience is like if I were to
floss my teeth and my gums bled and I
said oh flossing makes my gums bleed
better not do that yeah exactly when in
fact the gums bleeding is them crying
out because you need to floss it's a
good example it's so true though yeah
yeah so when when my gum is blue I'm
like [__] I gotta do this more okay
because I don't do as much either
I used to be one of these people who
cannot get away with not flossing and as
such just has this bacteria you know
that bacteria if you smell it in
people's mouths yes that's true that's I
all I was just talking about that yeah
if you kiss if you kiss like if I kiss a
girl like I could almost I'm like please
floss I just want to say that please
floss I'm not saying because it's there
you can smell the it's like when you
when you do the floss and you smell the
Slime yeah you're just like wow and
you're like you smell on someone's
breath it's because he didn't floss it's
because they didn't floss it's so gnarly
and our society is structured such that
it is not acceptable to tell somebody
hey man I need to talk to you as a
friend like I'm just telling you you got
a floss somebody somebody told me that
Colgate has like a thing you can call in
and they'll secretly send a package of
the person say hey somebody reported you
as having bad breath wow
you like and it blows out this is just a
dead animal sitting in your mouth that
just crawled by your tooth and died I
think about that all the time here's the
other fun fact I learned the plaque in
your mouth that that stays there
actually can seep through your gums into
your brain and it causes your hands
um amyloid beta plaques that eventually
cause Alzheimer's and God that's sonar
dementia and all that all like the the
plaques between your synapses right so
like your sit-ups that are firing
remembering where your keys are and then
you have plaque buildup and you just
don't remember anymore because
that's what the research says is that
saunas like being in in in a hot extreme
heat exposure creates these heat shock
proteins that that uh cut through the
plaque
so I get very excited about that stuff
I'm over here freaking out I haven't
flossed in like a decade
it's been a long time since I've lost
it's in a very long time I can tell you
that I have not smelled that bacteria
coming out of your mouth okay great
honest yeah
Scott and I made him pact when we
started working together almost 10 years
ago that if either of us smell that on
each other that like give them a heads
up dude you gotta tell me yeah I think
it's important I think like you know
it's like if you start off with a
preface like I'm not saying this to be
mean right I'm saying it's like to
benefit you right
right I remember a dentist telling me
that I went to a dentist he told me that
and then I just realized oh my God
that's why uh people have told me dude
your breath and I'm like I just brushed
my teeth they're like yeah but your
breath you know and one time I got in
the van with the jackass guys and we man
says dude Stevo your breath and then
Knoxville says saying Stevo has bad
breath is like saying wee man is short
[Laughter]
and and people would tell me like your
brother I just didn't know yeah and then
when I the dentist told me that one time
in 2009 ever I don't think I've had that
ever since I'm very Vigilant about my
oral hygiene water pick floss wow brush
tongue scrape the tongue scrape is like
something I don't do oh dude it's a big
one yeah but what but like like I mean
obviously it scrapes all the bacteria
and gross stuff off your tongue but is
that is that something you should do so
it doesn't build up over time or I I
just think the the bacteria building up
on your tongue is a threat to your
breath yeah and anybody who knows me
knows that when they hear violent
gagging it's the worst that that's me
because because I go to scrape my tongue
so far back that I I violently gag every
time I do it four in the morning on a
tour bus yeah
yeah
um and and what what a fascinating uh
discussion but what I want to know I've
seen you do Aoki jumps like on private
jets and like like
do you have a top Aoki jump and and
apologies if that's such a generic
question no no it's not it's actually I
don't think I've ever been asked that
question and I'm and like it's like my
thing
um I've done
I I've done more than what I've numbered
because I number them yeah I've numbered
them from 2012 since like the beginning
of Instagram I started so right like I
think the first month of Instagram was
my first Aoki jump it was in Miami
on the beach I remember that and and
I've done over like a Thousand Eleven
Hundred or something that I've
documented
um
it's hard to pick a favorite one I just
said so many a lot of them have a chat
pretty sick yeah oh yeah on top of the
private jet yeah yeah that's pretty epic
that's pretty epic
um I did one in the hospital
because I hurt my neck and I did one
like while I was in the gurney so it was
a fake jump I have my feet up like this
like the neck brace on in in Puerto Rico
after I like I screwed my neck up really
bad from jumping off this DJ booth and
um
so I remember that one
because experience was so like yeah yeah
on the private jet one like that had to
have been I mean did they check out the
jet after you did that to make sure that
the jet wasn't compromised right I mean
if you think of some some guys jumping
on the win like I don't want to get in
there I've done it a few times where I'm
I'm on top of the Jet right right so
I've been like it climbed on the wing
and then climbed on the very very top
and then I jumped and then yeah of
course like you know I'm asking the
permissions and making sure right is
this like cool is this like you know and
they're like it's totally fine so you
know we were able to do it and these are
like small airports with like probably a
lot less restrictions and regulations
you know man we uh met up with the pilot
and talked to uh we've actually met him
at the airport and we're and I was like
Hey dude I wanna uh duct tape myself to
a plane and that we were initially
before we did it was the build one truck
and I was driving down the highway duct
tape to it it was supposed to be an
airplane and I was duct taped to it and
the guy was the guy ended up getting
cold feet after agreeing to it like well
he was down as [__] and then when we
actually showed up at the plane with the
stunt guy the stunt coordinator and like
three other people he was like you could
just see like he's like I can't lose my
pilot's license
you know so I had a story like this so I
was on a plane uh and this this uh this
pilot is
the homie he was awesome and
um
he was you know we're flying up in there
and he's like yo look to the right and
then we look to the right and boom the
plane just does a
like a flip
a plane doing a full-on flip okay
and we're like whoa oh [__] this is
crazy yo and like and then we're like
can you do it again we gotta film it oh
wait wait wait the plane viewer in yes
did the barrel yeah so we're like going
up and then he's like yo look to the
right like look outside then boom he
does a barrel roll and then we go I'm
like oh can you do it again he's like so
he was so cool and then he goes out and
he and I'm like can we do it again
filming this time and then he does it
again and then you know I put it up on
on the gram you know and then
poor guy lost his license oh man but I
feel so bad about that because I he was
the best pilot I ever he was just so
cool damn you know like you know the guy
would just like do like stuff like that
and you know you don't want to like you
want to get him and try I don't want to
get him in trouble yeah you know what I
mean like he's not doing anything like
you know
I mean I did I did a rebel stunt plane
once like with uh Carey chambliss and
that was I mean we did we did like 30
barrels yeah front flips we did like
going up and draw and then turning off
the engine and him like falling down and
then flipping all the way down going
straight down as if like now I know what
it feels like to go nosedive and die and
then coming back out of that through you
know six G's out up like that was
one of the most epic bucket list items
for sure for me I I feel like that that
jerk that has to one up everybody but uh
it's a little bit different yeah like I
didn't do as much cool stunts as you
just described but when we were in
Russia filming wild boys which was
actually the final ever wild boys trip
um I got in a Russian Mig fighter jet
and went faster than the speed of sound
oh my God all the way to the edge of the
Earth's atmosphere oh my God that's
incredible where like it was not a cloud
in the sky like blue and it was noon
fully sunny day and we went up to the
point where it was just straight dark
and I was looking at the Earth from like
from Darkness still lower than the
Earth's atmosphere and I remember I
asked the pilot
um does this make me an astronaut and
the pilot this Russia is yes
Chris Pontius went on to uh to to
dispute that he said if you go to the
edge of a woman's [__] you're still a
virgin
this is why you're on TV
stupid [__] like this
it's too [__] good oh my God on the
way back down we did do barrel rolls you
know there wasn't like like uh did you
do any G's I mean dude like out of the
whole experience because I hate roller
coasters I hate like you know but out of
the whole experience it was just a
claustrophobia issue because it was just
such a tiny space that we were in like
that's got to be one of the coolest
things you've ever done it's definitely
up there yeah when you went up to the
edge was the earth flat or was there a
curvature
spoiler alert the Earth was not flat but
I'll tell you what is flat extremely
sharp and super high quality and that is
my razors from Harry's now listen here
and listen close because this is a deal
that you're out of your mind if you
don't jump on Harry's is the best men's
shaving products out there no gimmicks
it's just classy and good I've been
using them for over three years now it's
all I use Harry's and they've got this
starter kit for you it's got the five
blade German engineered razor the
weighted ergonomic handle the foaming
shave gel the travel cover this starter
kit is a 13 value and you can have it
for only three dollars if you go to
harrys.com
Stevo again I swear by these products I
can't stand not having a good shave and
you should too so go to harrys.com Stevo
jump on this deal and enjoy let's get
back to it
total curvature and I remember uh
posting the like footage of it or the
footage I took this photo from and uh
saying like you know it's about the Flat
Earth people see like I think I can kind
of set this to rest and they were like
fish I learned
the flattered thing I mean we just got
back from Australia and we're going back
to Australia again
um like I want to know what the Flat
Earth people when we're leaving from L.A
and we're going the opposite direction
because going the other way around the
globe is Right wouldn't that or time
zones
there's a lot there's a lot they're like
you just right but let's not say start
time with that
um so I was watching this
Wall Street Journal interview that uh I
think it was probably fairly recent and
uh it was fascinating and this this this
guy just who was interviewing him he's
like so when you're making like half a
million dollars per night per show like
how can these casinos justify and I just
thought wow that guy kind of like went
straight into the money question and you
were so cool and candid about it you
know like you know it's Wall Street
Journal
this is like what they think about is
like money everything is finance or
economy or like uh you know I don't mind
that at all it's just it's actually
really it's a really good question that
he did ask right because like you think
about this money that gets paid these
like really high fees that get paid to
artists or comedians or whatever right
right and like like it's all but it all
has to make sense
it all has to even out of course you
take the risks as as a promoter or as as
a casino or as you know booking a DJ or
anyone right and you think they're gonna
bring in this amount of number
and it doesn't and then you lose money
and but you don't book them again right
that's just what happens like and then
you get better at who you end up booking
I would have guessed if uh if somebody
posed that question to me about DJs and
and like just how insane the amount of
money they're paid is
my mind would go to
the insane amount of money that Netflix
pays to a Dave Chappelle or Chris Rock
or a Chris Rock or uh you know which is
how much I mean
Dave Chappelle did three for a hundred
million yeah somebody said three for 60.
so that's 20 million per special yeah
but didn't they just give 20 million to
Chris Rock they gave him 40. and then
riding in cars with comedians did a lot
right and now in in that scenario I
gotta believe that you can't justify
that payout on like money that it's
bringing in that it's really more in a
bigger picture sense they're trying to
invest in their brand and like have that
cachet and that Prestige of having done
that and that it's way long term down
the line that they expect that to
actually it's like the music side of
things like for example like Rolling
Stones when they do shows the promoter
you know how much they get when they do
a show if they like pick a promoter
because they have to pick someone to
like organize their show like an AEG or
a Live Nation yeah but they usually pick
like someone else they they only give
that person one percent
okay and and that person's gonna take it
and they're they're basically making
like nothing
but they're doing the Rolling Stones
show right and having that Rolling Stone
show
they could do a bunch of other things
and they have the access and the and the
relationships right built on that you
know I mean you have to be a very you
can't just be a random going I'll do it
it's one percent you know you have to be
like the top top top to even book a
rolling stone show right but you know on
Dave Matthews Band like a lot of these
these groups they know they're worth
and so they can command that that dollar
amount and like it's there's no one
bigger there's no one bigger than Chris
Rock right now after what happened right
you know so it's like he could command
it and they it's like this it's like a
huge Mark like you know in this case
it's a marketing push going okay well
this is going to get everyone in right
whatever maybe it does I heard Jay-Z
gets 120 of the door so that's he makes
the money
no what I mean by that is he gets the
parking lot money he gets the concession
stands and then they get whatever left
over because he's bringing what's the
Rose Bowl I mean that's massive right
and all the parking that could be even
wrong with the Rolling Stones
because this is like what I've heard
just from like the game of telephone it
could be like zero
yeah you know it could be a zero you
know like you just have to do the
shackle free I think that the quest the
question becomes like what's going on
with the food and beverage you know like
the the beer money the hot dogs you know
the the merch like all that going on but
I think that that you know again my what
I would guess is that when you've got
like one of these big Las Vegas casinos
paying you an insane amount of money
it's because
the Las Vegas casino
like ecosystem is like a game of who's
the cool kid you know like like what
what table just did the cool kids sit at
and by having Steve Aoki at that casino
that gives that casino that shine that
Prestige and that makes that casino the
one that people think is the cool one
that they want to go and and put their
money into when they come to Vegas and
well here's the thing too with Vegas the
casinos generally don't operate the
clubs
in one case Resorts World they operate
zuke okay so like they're involved
they're hand in hand but like from for
me for example I'm with Tau group and
Tau group has hakasam which is inside
MGM okay
um Omnia which is inside Caesar's Palace
there are two competing casinos so right
and then they have Tau and they have
Marquis which is inside Cosmopolitan so
they have they manage a bunch of
different clubs and they have
Partnerships with those casinos but they
are essentially they're the ones footing
the bill and there it's 100 not a
marketing thing they have to make money
off these DJs so there you go you have
to and if they're if the DJs aren't
bringing in what they expected them to
bring in when that contract's up
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
play most likely not playing with them
you know like and so that's what happens
like I've seen it you know because I've
had a residency in Vegas since 2010 and
I started with the win group
um and I was there for three years four
years 2014 I moved over to takasan group
and I I was DJing it for a hakasan and
hakkasan and opened up Omnia at Caesar
so now I've been with them for 10 years
and and uh you know I just seen the DJs
that like had the had the shine they had
their moment with their song or whatever
record that that blew them up and then
they couldn't follow
up with it for whatever reason and Vegas
is the most important thing to know
about Vegas is it's not a trend setting
City
you don't break records here right you
don't break moments here they have to
already be broken
that's why you have the Celine Dions and
the Adele's and the Bruno the Bruno Mars
and Britney Spears and like you have to
have already made it
because you don't like it's the lowest
it's kind of like I would say lowest
hanging fruit but it's like people are
here just to have a good time they don't
necessarily when they I already know
when they come to a Steve Aoki show I
already assume they know maybe one song
and they don't even know the name of it
right you know they're just coming
they're like yo aoki's crazy he's like
he's like throwing cakes I don't throw
cakes in Vegas but you know he's he's
just like you know like I have
I keep my entertainment level really
high level everywhere I go not just for
Vegas but just because I enjoy it but
sure yeah but it it resonates over time
you know and so
at the end of the day you know you have
to think like the the club the room of
Las Vegas is a room that just wants to
have a good time and you have to you
have to truly be a DJ more of a DJ and
less of an artist
whereas at a festival you're more of an
artist less of a DJ and what I mean by
that is like when you're an artist you
play all your unreleased music your all
your records all all the songs that
Define you okay musically the you know
the songs that aren't necessarily like
the big records that the that the
culture knows you know right and like
the songs that are pushing the needle
for the for like that genre and then as
a DJ you have to read the room and and
and go please the crowd yes and it's not
necessarily like I do play my music of
course I have to but but I I'm like
thinking about how to get everyone's
attention at all times right and if I
lose that like their attention I have to
figure out how to get it back with the
surprise with something that's familiar
you know with some kind of moment that I
can do outside of the music
you know and that's why I think about
like the cakes and like I used to do a
raft and I said raft over the crowd I
used to do some Stevo jumps from like
really high into the draft you know like
things like that so right why don't you
throw cakes in Vegas
um because it's messy and they don't
want to deal with the liability yeah and
and uh they just they just don't want to
deal with all that stuff and my show is
like I haven't done cakes here in
probably
five years
maybe longer yeah
um and it's still like a pretty you know
it's a solid show so like I don't need I
don't need the cakes here although I
have like the like cake me signs up you
know
um
but yeah that's like excited to tour
everywhere else you know for sure thank
you for asking that because I was dying
to know why you don't throw cakes in
Vegas and thank you for clarifying like
uh the reality here it's it's
fascinating that there's just that much
money coming in and that it's not of the
the difference between marketing and
business is uh that's a really good
distinction and I'm glad that you made
it man it what's the capacity when
you're doing a hakkasan gig in Vegas
Pakistan is small
I feel like I could be wrong it's two to
three thousand or something like that
but it does feel like more intimate
Omnia is um it's that club that's got
the chandelier that comes down looks
like a like you're in like a spacecraft
kind of thing it's a like incredible
like Alien Probe that comes down
um that I think they spent like 150
million dollars building that club too
it's like like the most opulent most
insane looking Club on on the planet
that club's quite big it I think it's
like four or five thousand or something
like that
um and then there's like what Republic
which I play quite a lot it's like pool
parties here
um and those pool parties can can be
really big too I think in the thousands
obviously wow
um
so I mean just doing the math like uh
people they got to be charging people
quite a bit to even get in there huh I
think girls just just generally get in
for free nice you know I I think that's
just how it works here and
um the tables are are the money
generators you know okay uh GA general
admission
um they fill it up and you know I'm not
sure I'm not sure how much they charge I
don't think it's like exorbitant amount
of money
um and I mean if you buy a table and
you're spending lots of
you know whatever you know that's that's
how they're able to make like sometimes
a million dollar a day yeah
so it's like yeah it's crazy yeah
um to take the comparison between uh DJs
and comedy
um I'm a guy who is known for
jackass then all of a sudden I start
doing stand-up and there are other
people who have come from other areas
and then moved over into stand up and
it's always kind of like some resistance
like ah what's this guy doing you know
and clearly people have done that with
DJing as well
but again my uh you know uneducated
observation is that when you're doing
stand-up comedy it is a lonely place to
be if you're on stage just you and a
microphone and a whole bunch of people
if you don't have the goods for those
people then your like time doing
stand-up comedy Is Not Gonna Last you
know you kind of like so I think that
there's less of a of a reason to give
people a hard time for getting into
stand up because it's whether you got it
or you don't that's gonna be the the
question but I imagine being a DJ
that like that that resistance to
celebrity DJs might be a little bit more
Justified because people could be up
there just hit and play yeah doing
nothing Well actually the the actual
DJing is not difficult
the actual mixing is not difficult that
doesn't take that much time I think you
could say the same thing about
skateboarding
it's not difficult to ollie yeah it is
it's it's it's okay
well I mean if you were to tell a kid
do this over and over and over and over
and over again for a month and you'll
Ollie yeah okay this is what I'm saying
right like it's not difficult to play
guitar okay yeah like you could learn a
whole song in a month if you do it and
you watch YouTube tutorial and you just
play the whole thing over and over and
over again it's not difficult to play
drums and get them matching down with
your with your kick on your foot and the
timing with your hi-hat you just have to
do it again and again I think with
mixing and listening to music and all
that stuff it's like in the the buttons
it might it might look kind of
daunting a lot you know when you stare
at this thing at a mixing board even
like producing music all these things
and I know people like are saying well
DJing is supposed to be easy yes it is
that's not the hard part
the hard part is standing in front of a
crowd
and playing music Here's another thing
I'm gonna I'm gonna rewind so a lot of
people think that DJing
um that most DJs don't DJ they just push
one button and it just plays and they
just up there like this
I I don't believe that okay I know well
like to answer that question to those
people
it's too easy
to just learn
like you know like
I'm unbutton and then like faking it
it's like I think it's more difficult
because you have to like pretend and you
have to like do all this other stuff
that you don't even know what you're
doing that's that's harder and it's and
it's more boring like I want to be doing
something that's actually tweaking the
sound doing something and and then yes
once I press play on one of the cdjs
it's playing right so when it's playing
and I'm not mixing then I can go grab my
cake and I can cake someone okay you
know and then like the song ends I'm
like hey it's okay I just kick someone
I'm walking back to Stage everyone's
cool
then I get back on and like play the
next song but essentially the act of
DJing is not a difficult thing and and
it's more about
curating curating your your your set
making sure it's like a story that
you're trying to tell you know a musical
story you're trying to tell the mixing
part you could actually get better and
better and better at mixing and making
it seamless and so when you want to get
the technical detail of the mix and
you're listening to a mix and you can
hear like when certain things like when
when the trouble like when certain
sounds come in and certain you know
sounds are are coming out in a certain
way if you're listening to that detail
then you're like wow and that's when you
go go into these more like all night
Raves and techno parties where you know
you're in there for six hours like it's
all about that mix and feeling that
emotional drive it is a psychology it is
a psychology for sure do you ever DJ for
six hours I've done I've done like a
14-hour set wow is that one of your
Guinness World plaques no no that's like
oh my God that's nothing all right
especially for like techno DJs and house
DJs like on the regular like if you're
in that space you're like you have to be
doing five to eight hour ten hour sets
so but like
like it's you know just like everything
just like in comedy just like in music
genres there's so many genres within EDM
yeah and the genre that Steve Aoki is
known for is
is like pure EDM it's it's like it's
very it's entertaining it's an
entertainment dance music almost like I
want to call it like that and I'm
pulling putting like a full-on
like I'm like a Ferrari we're going like
[__] in the red the entire time like
I'm gonna push it all the way I love
that man and frankly I like to live my
life in the red too just going for it
full force never stop but that can come
with the price and that is why I'm so
glad this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp.com because I strongly
believe in the value of therapy and if
you've been thinking about trying
therapy let me tell you about
betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p.com it's just a very simple way
to get matched up with the licensed
therapist it's all online so it's super
convenient and easy to work with your
schedule if you're not happy with the
therapist or for any reason you want to
switch you can absolutely switch at no
extra cost and it just helped helps man
it helps my relationship it helps my
peace of mind and I think it can help
you so if you go to betterhelp.com
Stevo you can get 10 off your first
month and it is well worth looking into
again if you've been thinking about
trying therapy I urge you to follow that
instinct and follow it right to
betterhelp.com
Stevo now let's get back to it so my set
is generally 90 minutes to two hours
right
um and pushing it just means the Beats
just I mean there there is a web and
flow but when I push it it's like it's
maximal it's like at the it's like I
want to completely like my whole point
is if I can get people like just rip
their shirts off and [__] scream
because they're just they just want to
feel that moment if I could see that
happening I did my job you know like
it's it's supposed to like I'm trying to
get like you out of your skin and that
matters on the bpms the beats per minute
not really because I I do I do it across
the board
um you could you could make someone feel
that way at
120 128 is like my my core BPM Tempo but
I go as high as 170. 150 160 like you
know and that's also just like
bouncy music I don't know if you want to
call it that but you know but um when
you're up there are you like looking at
somebody like I'm gonna get this guy to
[__] take his shirt off it already
happens
it already happens you know I mean my
shirt's off
halfway through the set my shirt's off
wow for good reason I mean I got we got
in the the sauna too and I'm like man
like uh I'm flabby
you're not you're not flabby at all dude
it's uh it's impressive
you said that um the artist versus the
DJ it sounded to me like you were saying
the artist is the one uh creating music
original music right that they make
themselves whereas a DJ is more curating
just the like the music that's in The
Ether already right exactly yeah so
I and when we were in your house I saw
like four billion streams on Spotify was
that that's a pretty badass plaque yeah
that that's epic and that presumably is
for music that you created original
music from scratch yes yes yeah mainly
originals and then You Know sample
sampling like Classics and uh remixing
them but generally it's Originals when
you sample classic music into your
original music
um like that means that you're splitting
the the publishing like the the music
the revenue with that yeah the owner of
that or that sample well I'll give you
examples so I just my last record I just
dropped it last weekend it's called wild
okay based on born to be wild Born yeah
Steppenwolf yeah yeah exactly so I took
that sample born be wild I did it with
uh these incredible DJs called vinivichi
and put on put on the side trance drop
and it's a banger at the at the shows
everyone's just jumping going crazy to
it now when you go to the back end of
that record
100 of the publishing went to
Steppenwolf wow I mean it doesn't always
go like that but some people are like if
you're gonna use our sample we're gonna
give you nothing and you're gonna like
it
we're lucky to even give it to you kind
of thing so um so I mean I've done that
before we're a hundred percent of the
pub goes to them and even though I did
that with with popcorn as well popcorns
like this really classic sample by
Gershon Mosley
um that eventually got remade by hot
buttered it's a 1967 sample like
I don't know if you know this one but
like that's like that's like the first
electronic Melody as far as like 1967.
um and uh and that that's I was lucky to
even clear that song we had to send
you know to the estate every single week
I was sending popcorn my label was
sending popcorn to the to the estate
because he doesn't receive uh emails he
can only like knock on his door or call
him wow and um but he's like it's 100
like you get zero Pub
that sounds to me like
um the the artist who does the Super
Bowl Halftime gets paid nothing but it's
just so much exposure that it's always
worth it and when you're sampling Born
to Be Wild on the song I mean it's kind
of guaranteed to be such a banger yeah
that like it benefits you like during
the Super Bowl halftime show you want to
have a hit even though the actual amount
of time on the the total track right is
maybe in total with both times he's like
he sings it is maybe like six seconds
and for eight seconds and it doesn't
Loop no it only happens twice it says
one time before the first drop and the
second time we glitch out his voice so
you could barely even tell he's saying
it so you could really only hear the one
time but it's such a strong sample and
we don't want to
not use it like we could have easily
just put on like another sample that's
free right but like the sample is too
good so do you ask permission or do you
try to get clearance before you make the
song or do you go ahead and make the
song first and then show it to them yeah
you can do that and and when like here's
another example with uh I Think Like a
Rolling Stones is that
they
it's like you you can do that but then
like
they'll come after you right and they're
going to take all the pub so if you do
it beforehand
you you can actually try to negotiate
and so in some cases where I've I've
like taken a really strong example I've
taken at least like maybe like 10 15 20
of the pub because I did a sizal
production
I think when she's asking though is not
putting it out but just making it yeah
yeah just making the songs they have
have this song to put out look how rad
it is
so I'll give you another example so I
made a record with Dimitri Vegas who's a
good friend of mine from uh Europe and
we we sampled the White Lotus theme
oh wow okay
and we didn't ask any permission at all
to Netflix or you know White Lotus at
all we just put it out
and um and then they took it down
it was up for it was up for a month it
literally got it was number one up where
it was up on Spotify Apple everything
and and it was it got number one in this
website called 1001
tracklists which shows all the DJs
playing this record
so everyone was playing our White Lotus
theme sample house record because it's a
it's a great track it works so good the
sample is so interesting and weird
whether you watch a show or not and for
for like a month it was number one most
played by all DJs around the world being
recorded by this website and it doesn't
matter so they just took it down there
no you're out they took it down and
demanded the publishing money no they
just took it down they just took it down
I mean in the world of artificial
intelligence that they had to have known
about it right away but Tiesto's
versions still up there because he got
cleared so I was like because I remember
we had this conversation
me and the other producer on the on the
record and we're like we should clear
this thing right because it's so good
you know and he's like well if we clear
it it's gonna take months and then and
then the show's over
so the hype's gone so we're like let's
just let's just [__] run with it so
we there was no panel tape for running
yeah we just we just did it and it was
cool for the moment and you know and and
like the talk on White Lotus is over and
Sample is cool but like I'm not really
playing it anymore so it was like good
for its moment all right
um with uh with
collabing with other artists is there
ever like Like a Rolling Stones kind of
a situation where they'd like I'll
collab with you on a track but I get all
the pub
um no no I've been I haven't I haven't
seen that because like if we're both
working on the record like let's you
can't really right but you but
actually
I haven't really experienced this that
deep but when there's a lot of writers
then it can be like well I did this much
you know because right like on some
records there might be like eight
writers right because it's not just
whoever's producing the music but you
have the melody writers the the the the
actual lyrical writers
um the singer that might have wrote like
maybe a lyric
because all you have to write is one you
can write you can write like no you can
write the yeah okay like let's change
this to am to the like you could
literally write just something a little
bit different and you get a piece of the
pub right so
um and and like all that comes into play
and then it's just sometimes a mess and
then also Egos and like right who's the
bigger name and things like that and I
don't deal with any of that stuff
so there's I'm sure I'm sure like that
that's been a a hurdle that my
management had to jump over yeah that's
great that's great news that you don't
have to deal with that
um on The Tribe Called Quest album that
came out it was like their first album
in I don't know how many years but they
had Elton John not only did they
um
sample one of Elton John's classic Tunes
it's a wall of sound and but they also
had Elton John record in the studio
it serves both double dip wow sample and
feature yeah
um I don't know he's featured on drug
called quest and it's the most
incredible song that album is so damn
good wow it's uh it's it's wild and I
would love to know what it took to both
sample and get you know get the future
yeah I can picture that being a 100 Pub
situation yeah I have so many records
I've done with amazing artists that
never came out
like we have finished songs that just
from management
from the record label saying No this
doesn't fit within the timeline and then
time goes by and then the song just kind
of gets stuck in this back burner I'm
like what about this great song we made
you know and it's it's just gone it's
like gone in the dust it's great moments
with amazing artists that would you know
the fans from both the artists I mean
fans all over the place would absolutely
love to hear and it's it like hurts my
soul sometimes when I like think about
that didn't Michael Jackson like
continue putting out music like for
years and years after he died because
there were so many situations like that
like Prince has so much uh I bet like
music in the archives too
um secure with a record label I have my
own label there there you go
I was with the label for 10 years and
when I didn't have the money to to foot
the bill on on you know because when you
do an album I've done seven Studio
albums and each album you know I have
they're all features with different
singers or bands or artists or other
producers it's a costly you know six
figures to to seven figures sometimes
you know on cost on paying out and
making sure that everyone's paid out
before even and cleared if you're gonna
spend that much doing it though are you
then buying out the artist's
contribution no no they're like they're
they're still like on the master side I
don't know exactly what the deals look
like but on the pub we're we're sharing
you know sometimes the artists don't
sing the song I mean don't they sing the
song where they don't write the song
right so I'm working with the
songwriters um but you've been in my
house you see how big my house is I've
had songwriting camps at my house and we
turn out like lots of songs in all those
rooms yeah it's it sounds a bit to me
like like movies where like when I when
I do a jackass movie I've got my my
upfront money and then I've got like the
back end percentage Yeah so like you
gotta the budget's going to pay the
artist up front yeah and then they get
the back end too so the first the first
10 years of my career
I just didn't I couldn't afford spending
that kind of money and then like at a
label going okay we're gonna give you
this advance and we're gonna pay for all
this and then you're gonna get your
small percentage at the end I was like
fine this is great right and then but
they own my music in perpetuity forever
I but at the time I was like you know
what they're paying for it all I guess
it's fine but now I'm like yeah you know
it's like I don't care how much it costs
how much my albums cost like my last
album was 24 tracks 21 songs 25 I think
25 tracks 21 tracks with different
artists and like
four or five interludes and um I pay for
the whole thing myself
I I don't care about the costs anymore
you know it's just like anything you
invest in your own now I have the money
to do that and I don't care if it
if it does badly it's okay because it's
it's like I own it can we agree that
this is pretty much the best episode
ever and get ready because we're gonna
talk about
anti-aging and everything that we can do
to stay young as we get old and spoiler
alert it's all about sleep baby I happen
to be reaching an age where sleep is the
most important thing to me and that is
why my mattress is so crucial and if
you're even thinking about trading in
your disgusting old mattress for a
really good new one that's gonna get you
better sleep then I have the answer for
you and it is called Helix
sleep.com now you go to helixsleep.com
Stevo you take the simplest two minute
quiz so that you can be paired up with
the mattress that is scientifically best
for you and these people are so generous
to my listeners it's up to 350 off any
mattress purchase plus when you make
that purchase you get two free pillows
thrown in and Men their pillows are
unbelievably epic I love their
mattresses and I got a feeling that you
need a new one so go to Helix sleep.com
slash Devo jump on this epic deal up to
350 bucks off a mattress it's insane
helixsleep.com Stevo now let's get back
to it right so my label Denmark owns you
know I own it actually I own it and I
even license to my own label
like even one more step to know that
like I own it personally and I'm licing
into my label dimlock as a license yeah
and um and you know I just it's hard for
me to think to ever sure work with a
major or another label unless the money
was ridiculous and I I just don't care
that much anymore so I'm so happy I have
this Freedom moving forward right
I've always understood that there's like
a little bit of a like a catch-22 in
music that if you want to become big you
have to have a record deal with major
label but if you want to really make
money you have to own your music and
that's uh those are mutually exclusive
Concepts so you're kind of screwed in
the beginning no matter what yeah it's
true because the percentage is so small
and it's hard for these labels to even
recoup
right you know like like the idea to
recoup is like almost like I don't know
what the percentage is but I am assuming
it's going to be a tiny percentage that
they're they're going to recoup and
they're going to give you a royalty so
whatever Advance you get from that major
is pretty much the only money you're
gonna get I'd say like 99 of the time
I'm just taking a wild guess here that
that reminds me of book publishing like
uh I can't imagine ever getting any back
end uh on a book deal because it's so
hard for the publisher to recoup yeah
and I've done two books right right
um the uh
with the publishing and and the you know
owning your own regular creating your
own music like how if you were gonna put
the money you've made from music that
you've created
compared to like the personal appearance
you know from the shows like how how
would that like uh
yeah what's the pie chart
I'd say live shows
I'm gonna be very very kind of broad
sure it I I I'm assuming it's like
probably over 80 percent there you go of
my income maybe more
and um and then I do a lot of
endorsement deals
which is also quite high too sure so the
like the music making my royalties for
my music is actually a very small
percentage that four billion streams on
Spotify didn't pay [__] well think about
this so I think for every million
streams it's 400 bucks wow that's even
worse than YouTube yeah so you have to
go to one billion it's 404 million right
yeah CPM is uh cost per Millennia which
is one thousand that's four I think it's
four million you get four million
dollars for one billion streams
four million dollars is not going
straight to you
it's split up with whoever owns the
master yeah and then once it gets to the
to my side I have to pay my managers
sure I have to pay my business managers
I have to pay lawyers yeah I have to pay
all these people and I have a team yeah
you know you subsidize all those
different costs that I pay you make
you know twenty percent thirty percent
of the hundred you know so the reality
and then the taxes on top of that yeah
for sure so it's like it's it sounds
like a lot of money but then when you
just dice it up you realize you're only
getting the the tail of the fish I I
only just started really paying
attention to accounting and
um I I shouldn't say this but I'll go
ahead and I will but there was a period
of uh of time that we were looking at
where uh the accountants told me that I
generated 1.1 million dollars in Revenue
but I netted 97
000.
I'm not surprised yeah I'm not surprised
at all it's it's gnarly after tax no I
don't think that's after tax you got you
got maybe 50 Grand yeah I mean it's
after taxes after taxes okay stop that
would be crazy 1.1 million 50 Grand I
know but now our attention to be fair we
we found uh um an inventory discrepancy
which did add like like another 100 so
it was more like 1.1 million to 200
right but then again that's and that was
a in a year
and then you start spending you're like
I got 1.1 I could I could buy this I
could buy that I could buy this and then
and then the reality is you have you
have 100 grand
maybe you spend like 20 grand
20 grand tops right like that's your
that's your safety spend not not like
400 Grand yeah or 300 Grand whatever it
is you know like it's it's it's it's
insane it's absolutely insane like uh
how it all just vanishes this is why I
still fly Spirit do you I slew Spirit on
the spirit like I don't mind it that's
fantastic I mean I fly spirit I Fly
Southwest I fly uh
you know all these other airlines every
uh every airline that can get me well
you know Direct
I don't fly Spirit just fly Spirits
right right right right right well
that's all about flu spirit I literally
was stuck on the tarmac because like
there was like yelling and crying and
screaming going on like you know and
they wouldn't leave the plane but
um that's really cool man can you
imagine you're in Spirit Airlines and
it's sitting next to Steve Aoki well if
you're sitting next to me you like I'm
like it's impossible to talk to me
because I have noise cancellation
headphones on I got this huge like eye
mask and then I have a big pillow that
I'm already laying against and then I'm
just got a sweater that's like kind of
like hooded over to everything else like
good luck getting any more attention I'm
just out I'm real cold that yeah that's
crazy we might want to rethink our uh
our air travel
what is it uh yeah we we spent a a
boatload of money on air travel last
year I went everywhere on the tour bus
it makes no sense it's crazy it's like
you know I think about I still do
private jets and actually when I'm in
Europe I we just Charter Ridge up for
the whole summer and oh wow yeah we just
chartered for the whole summer get a
full bulk right on that I think it's
like in total like three 400 grand for
the whole summer that's insane yeah so
that's that's great for us because
Europe is like almost like flying across
the United States and doing shows right
but even better because every country is
maybe one or two hours apart right so
the the actual cost of me flying from
one country to another is the actual
cost may be like five grand if you bulk
rate it or four grand if you bulk rate
it right so then I'm able to fly my
whole team I have a bed in the back of
the plane I sleep right away
you know and that way I get in I also
leave later so I can sleep because one
of the main things going on in my life
right now is is just getting better
sleep wow this is coming up all over the
place it's supposed to talk to this guy
about that do you have a a way of
measuring your uh sleep stages you have
a whoop strip I got three tracking
devices
you got three two I've got two this
isn't uh an aura ring oh I was like that
looks okay so yeah you got two I got
three I checked them every morning how
much do we do we do we love whoop or are
you uh I'm a big a big Whooper
I love whoop um whoop it's interesting
whoop in the in the Apple watch because
they're on the risk it was wrist they
give me both very similar data or it
gives me different data okay it gives me
like worse data but it really worse data
I mean I mean probably it's probably
better data but like worse like the
information is not good you know like my
Ram is always [__] pissed you're
saying that you're uh you're getting
conflicting accounts very conservative
metrics on the whip I don't know if it's
because it's on the finger
I surely don't like it because my REM is
[__] horrible even with the ice baths
and the saunas I do everything I take
magnesium I take Trazodone Now 50
milligrams of that before I sleep I I do
like you know like some you know a
little bit of um
what's that called before you sleep
ecstasy uh melatonin
melatonin a little bit of that I do I do
like a whole sleep regimen I'm ready
you're like I do a red light I have a
red light therapy bed I just lay on the
red light therapy bed and put on sleep I
have a I have a [__] grounding mat
I'm on for 30 minutes I have a
hyperbaric chamber in my room I feel
like go all in on bio hacking you know
that that's why uh that's why you fly
Spirit
that's why you look so great
um and the next the only thing you're
missing is the the bringing in the 18
year old dudes to get their blood
transfusion fecal transfusion yeah I
heard about that the the blood plasma
the the younger blood plasma that you
can transfusing your in your blood sugar
to me but uh but I get it yeah well I
mean stem cells is is like somewhat
similar yeah have you done that I've
done that did you go to Colombia for
that I went down to Panama okay I went
to Medellin how was that Colombia this
place called bio accelerator Joe Rogan
talks about it all the time like uh
they've they've it's it's unbelievable
and you've got to go somewhere outside
of America because the
uh procedures that they do the
techniques are not legal in America and
it's not that they're illegal in America
because there's anything controversial
about where the stems come from they're
not even coming from like aborted babies
they're coming from the umbilical cords
of perfectly healthy babies that you
know and they replicate yeah you can
replicate there's nothing controversial
about the origin of the stem cells
what's controversial is uh allegedly
um the uh
the medical complex and medical
industrial complex doesn't want uh
solutions to uh health problems that
don't involve like getting paid for the
drugs and the farm Pharmaceuticals and
the operations and all that they want
people to be sick and so they can
operate on them and sell them drugs
right yeah I mean that's what it is a
speculation I heard
yeah there's definitely like the you
know the like in America there's like
the the church is so tied in with the
state kind of thing too which you know
and stem cells this is a controversial
point for for that yeah but that's
interesting and it doesn't make sense
because it's it's like for like you said
it's from an umbilical cord right it's
not from a baby it's not an aborted baby
it's a perfectly healthy baby that was
born and is happily living with its
mother and instead of throwing away the
umbilical cord they they uh Harvest it
for stem cells right and it replicates
over time I don't even know about it
replicating yeah I just think there's
just [__] on the stem cells in there
yeah why would Danny way you know Danny
yeah I know Dan yeah yeah yeah yeah like
it got his own Guinness World Record I
don't know if it was verified but the
most stem cells pumped into a human
being like in one go oh wow yeah I mean
dude he's so gnarly like the way he his
call
like he's just like The Bionic Man him
and Matt Hoffman have been operated on
so much yeah I guess it's like that's
that that's where it does help a
regeneration dude he's got no uh
cartilage
in his knees
oh my God and he's [__] skating I
think the last time I talked to him he
said that now his MRIs are showing
cartilage in his knee again and that's
just 100 from the stem cells when I was
when I was in Panama I saw
um a lot of kids that had muscle
dystrophy which means your muscles like
just disintegrate or deteriorate over
time yeah and they're there for stem
cells so there was some sort of program
that that was allowing them to get stem
cells so they can
regenerate their muscle tissue some some
like you know I don't know the science
behind it but you know
um that I was like really I was like wow
so that's helping kids that have this
you know sad disease and it's helping
people that want to heal faster in
certain areas of the body I like
shoulder issues so I went in there I got
um
shots in my shoulder an inner Venus
through the body just to you know do the
whole so you flush the hole and it it it
it it homes in on areas that need [__]
yeah it's like it's like it's like Navy
Seals coming in just one oh we got we
got a problem down here yeah yeah yeah
they do it intravenously through your
whole system and then they'll do it
locally where they just hit in one spot
that they know needs help I did run my
neck for degenerative disc disease and
how did that how does it feel after it
you know it's tough for me to really say
that how much it helped because I know
that the issue is there but it hasn't
gotten so bad yet so it was a little bit
preemptive
you know so I'm just a bad like example
I'm also whenever I think about things
like this I don't try to look for like
the immediate reaction because usually
immediate reactions are not real
you know they're right of course you
know of course like it's like how you
feel but it's always like with all the
stuff that I do it's like you have to
you have to do it a lot and you do over
time and then do a test from like you
know your Baseline right to three months
or six months later but by but yeah it
could only make sense if you're doing
something consistently
and then you could get a true reading
that yes plus even scientifically they
said that you know don't expect to see a
difference on uh an MRI or an x-ray like
for six months because it's going to
take that long for the stem cells to
actually like do their thing right and
you know but the one thing you can't
test is you know your HRV yeah because I
I that's one thing that I was you know
talking to Dan Bilzerian about it and he
says this HRV score it just doubled
after he took it something oh wow how
about that and he's he's like obsessed
with Diagnostics as well that's all we
do is like like 30 of our conversation
is literally on diagnostic check on okay
so what's going on with your health here
or where was your HRV group no no but
like we should are you in a book
I started one too dude I'm in I'm in
let's do it like you know um how are you
with your diet like like uh sugar like
thank you
you know when I go out to eat it just
everything's throughout the window like
I just say that Delilah's I have like
some dessert you know at the end and I
was like whatever but for now right now
I've been I've been pretty good
um in general like you know I have a I
have a I do these bets they keep me in
line that's my discipline okay without a
bet I can't keep get keep kept in line
it's it's so interesting how my brain
works I I I I have no ability to
moderate anything so I'm either like
like disastrously awful or I'm like
super disciplined and like doing great
right now I'm uh really doing well
avoiding sugar
um as soon as I had like screw up once
yeah you know I'm in the gas station
with the Reese's you know I like but
I I say that because my HRV
um depending on my my diet if I'm awful
my HIV is awful if I'm avoiding flour
and sugar and eating like a somewhat
responsible human being then my HRV is
way higher that's why it's so fun to
gamify this stuff yeah so that way you
like because like our our brains are
like they're intelligent but they're
also so primitive like you need to speak
to the dumb [__] guy inside of your
head and like gamify itself and trick it
like I have to trick my stupid brain
right with these bets dude you know like
and then I won't eat bread I mean just
because I put a bet on it like you know
with my friend it's an honor bed so I
could easily eat bread without even
knowing but like that it's 500 if if I
eat a piece of bread or pasta
um but like breaded chicken or you know
like there's Bread on things is okay but
like a piece of bread because I I love
bread and butter yeah at a dinner table
what I mean there's a beautiful bread
and butter at the dinner table yesterday
I was like I'm not touching that thing I
made a bread I'm gonna pay 500 bucks
[__] that
that in my mind I just won't do it you
know you kind of need this stupid thing
in your head it's like why can't I do it
without this bet you know what I mean
dude a perfect example of exactly what
you're talking about is my meditation
practice
um I keep track of it on an app and uh
if I skip a day I'm gonna lose this
streak like today uh 1188 straight days
what averaging more than 40 minutes of
meditating every single day oh my God I
do it twice a day today I'm 26 minutes
in so the way I view it I owe the
universe
15 minutes because I got to maintain
this is gamifying it's so good what's
this app uh this happened there's
nothing special about it like it doesn't
like uh it's not guided or anything I do
Mantra based meditation it's called
Center okay and dude like I'll be damned
if I'm gonna break that [__] Street
100 gaming fight and just like with my
diet if heaven forbid I skip one day of
meditation
it's out the window I'll never get it
back yeah I'll never get it back and and
like you know you know what's
interesting is so there's a uh like this
you know I love this like Tech
diagnostic stuff that like I keep
getting from different companies there's
one that I got that when it when you
meditate you're supposed to wear this
device
and it it does more of a diagnostic
check on your overall stress level
you're okay because what I've what also
what I've learned about longevity and
anti-aging is that you know clearly like
one one of the things caloric
restriction is gonna is is gonna amount
to you know saving lots of years on your
life but the overall stress level that
you have
over a long period of time is the one of
the the key tenets of living a longer
life than expected worrying so like it's
like meditation is so crucial I remember
when I did this I was wearing this this
thing and you put in your ears and you
have it testing on the back of your neck
now it's meditating it just immediately
you just I love seeing the graphs you
see everything you gotta looked me up
yeah you gotta hook me up with that
um and
like like we're worrying is so [__]
destructive yeah like uh stress and and
you know it's crazy
um with your renting a private jet for a
whole I gotta go back to this yeah it's
renting a private jet for a whole
[__] summer
does that mean that you don't even
bother with tour buses not in Europe
okay so but when you're in the states so
I only do that in Europe we work with a
company I've worked with them for 13
years now or maybe 15 years like every
time I'm in Europe I stayed there for a
few months and I have a residency and a
Visa so I rarely come back to America
unless I have to play in Vegas or I have
to play a certain Festival but generally
I'm just there I want to stay in one
time zone but when I'm here
I'm I'm traveling everything everything
commercial
and and the Spirit Airlines and Spirits
like I don't want to shout Spirit not so
[__] hard
not three okay they're not great I think
everybody knows that yeah
American I'll just shout them out
American is awesome because they because
like um concierge key
how'd you get that I'm sorry I don't
know but it's I'm I'm just happy to be
part of the concierge Key Club because
they they wait for you right when you
get out boom you're outside the the
plane into a nice car driven to the next
thing it's like amazing I'm so bummed on
American Airlines all right like when
did you become a million miler
[__] 10 years ago oh God I mean yeah
okay I've been doing 200 to 300 shows a
year every year for the past 18 years
yeah like I mean this is like my mileage
club on every Airline is crazy right
because I fly them all I fly United
Delta Southwest I fly every single
Airline what do you do with the frequent
flyer Mouse
um I you know what like I'm definitely
not optimizing on that well here's the
things uh Scott did this once he was he
he posted on his social media he said
I've got so many frequent flyer miles
and and I just want to like do something
good for somebody so so uh somebody
didn't send me your story and I'm gonna
go through their stories and pick
someone I'm just gonna give you uh I'd
like to do that right now ooh yeah I'd
like that because I have a [__] ton of
these but it has to be two people
because you don't want to send somebody
by themselves right of course of course
kids like if the story is good enough
yeah then
um then uh it's you and a guest to go
domestic
uh I mean can we not you're the only one
who buys My Flights can we not have used
miles to send anybody anywhere in the
world
yeah you could do that but sometimes
around the world is like 200 000 then
it's for now you just spent 400 000
points within America
100 years later within America now how
are how are they gonna get their story
to me they're gonna probably follow
Vinnie at skinny Vinny
we just got very
verified Vinnie Vinnie is going to be
the liaison yeah so they have to follow
you yeah they gotta follow skinny Vinnie
on Instagram they have to like one of
his cool videos on there yeah and they
they you know and they just gotta get
Vinnie's attention and and and
easy on the sob story if it's something
sincere that's great but like if it gets
you if you'll know who the person is for
sure I take that back SOB's story is fun
like whatever it's compelling we want
commercial I'm in you're gonna take Chad
Tepper now now Steve let me ask you this
like I gotta believe that we're flooding
Vinnie's uh Instagram with requests and
there's gonna be more than one
compelling request totally are you
interested at all in us making you aware
of uh so we can throw away some of your
frequent flyer miles on on one of these
Spirit Airlines
you know so on the first seats because
like because I just started flying
Spirit you know okay I never thought I
would ever do this and I'm like first my
first flight in Spirit Airlines is 45
you know so
um uh the the front seat is only 40
extra bucks
all right yeah that's what I was saying
that's what I was telling you he was
like what airline do you want to fly I
was like dude put me in spirit I want
that fat front yeah but it doesn't
recline it doesn't recline but for me
I'm a big dude so it's nicer than
sitting in the back of them yeah I mean
I flew from Miami to Vegas that's five
hours on Spirit that's a long flight you
don't fly like American lay down seat on
the way to Miami
I prefer mint you know like the the Jet
Blue but they don't have that option
because I had to get back I remember I
was in Friday night this has just
happened so Friday night I played Miami
in my Denmark party Saturday I had to
fly out like at eight in the morning the
only flight out to get me to play my Wet
Republic show at 3 P.M and then right
after What republic I took a private jet
to
Veracruz Mexico which is five hours
south
America's yeah that's not like that
that's like uh not even
uh enough if like a big I don't want to
say like uh it's an underdeveloped okay
so here's the thing I want to tell you
about Mexico so I played all over Mexico
I played in the the center of of uh I
played like Leon to 150 000 people I
played like cities that you've you've
probably not have ever heard of I I've
heard of Mostly because like when we did
wild boys we went everywhere and that's
if you go to August Calientes I'm not
I'm not trying to just remember Veracruz
because I I've met a champion Veracruz
that I was pretty jazzed out and I flew
her to La so Veracruz is like I remember
so yeah yeah with a girl of course you
can remember that I was Calientes is a
hot water right hot water okay the city
this is my biggest show I've ever played
in my whole career it was like 250 000
people wow it's just like these cities
you don't know about the whole place
comes out yeah you know and it was like
I was like centered in in the middle of
the street in the middle of like this
whole city so like my stage is built up
there's like TVs everywhere so that like
the whole city would come out and watch
the show if they couldn't get to like
the Center Street which was filled like
four blocks down
what a satisfying experience it really
is the it's the greatest High
to ever experience I and I don't I never
got into cocaine or I never got into
like serious drugs to get those serious
highs
but I can't imagine a high that comes
close the Endorphin release the like the
scientific if I if I was to somehow do
my neurofeedback or some sort of brain
scan on the brain after a show
I don't like that the adrenaline the
endorphins the whatever else is
happening my brain
I'm the happiest I've ever been it's
it's I just hope it's like I don't want
to lose playing shows it's the greatest
feeling in the world that's why I do 200
300 shows a year and 45 I'm trying to
keep my body my mind my spirit like
super strong so I can
do this like I don't have an intention
to retire you know because it's just
right this is my
my soul is definitely feeling this
hundred percent too so for sure
um quick question Scott uh what was the
story of the person that you gave that
trip to then it a couple times
um I don't remember kind of like someone
that their father was the meaning of
cancer yeah and um
and I flew out their daughter right the
original winner wanted she's never seen
the ocean before and she wanted to fly
to the Oregon coast see her sister but
she died before she did it so I ended up
flying out her daughter I believe okay
so whatever we've we've established it I
feel really good I gotta get in on this
too so yeah you did ask me about that so
yeah count me in I don't know how but
it's like I finished gonna be the the
goat he's only gonna send me the really
good ones yeah and of the really good
ones I'll send you like when I think I
heard the really really good ones you
pick it or maybe they can go to one of
your shoes to go to one of your shows or
something yeah come to my show in Vegas
let's fly into Vegas yeah and then they
can we can get them in we can get him
into the show I don't necessarily think
it's a matter of like come flying them
to us like what we want is like a trip
that's gonna be meaningful to someone
like why do you need to to get on an
airplane and go do something what is the
compelling reason why you have to like
uh make this trip and we want to make
that trip happen for you and I want to
make sure that it's not just like I'm
sending somebody on a trip and they
gotta like we're gonna I'm gonna pay for
their hotels and and uh you know they're
they're fear and everything it's going
to be an all-expensive paid trip for
someone who really needs to go on a trip
and I love that we're doing this at the
tail end of the podcast because I'm
always so like profoundly grateful for
the people who really stick with it and
you know because we tend to streets
it's the street team so dude man like
this has been epic is there anything
that we can uh draw attention to and
promote you said you just had a song
come out last week yeah yeah wild with
bdb2 that just came out
um I just started a uh music Grading
Company
so I was showing that to you guys we
didn't talk about the trading cards yeah
yeah I mean like that's a whole long one
but
um so clearly I'm into trading cards I'm
into like Collectibles I love
Collectibles and and the thing with
Collectibles is whenever you encase them
and encapsulate them like PSA does with
cards right comic books get they get
graded get graded and encapsulated now
video games are selling for millions of
dollars that are that are encapsulated
and graded like Mike Tyson's punch out
it's probably pretty bad that's gonna be
that's gonna be in the six figures for
sure 100 wow the um the VHS tapes are
getting graded and sold
first six figures I gave the first Star
Wars you know like like if you had a
seal Star Wars
there's a lot and now
why isn't vinyl I know it's supposed to
be played how about skateboards
skateboards I mean anything but that's
why I've started this company audio
media grading to encapsulate and grade
all music collections so not just vinyl
but vinyl CDs cassette tapes a track and
now we're going to do reels we're gonna
do everything in music and we're you
know reaching out to all the the big
audiophile collectors as well to to get
their Grails encapsulated and help sell
them and create a secondary you know
this is an alternative asset this is
we're going to create a secondary income
stream and and build a community around
grading and encapsulating music
collections yeah that's really cool it's
really exciting I'm like I have a like
an insane vinyl collection it's my first
thing that I got into when I how many
pieces of vinyl do you have I you know
it's interesting it's not like I have
this crazy amount like I had a call with
Craig Coleman the head of Atlantic he
has two million two million pieces of
vinyl so I have like a couple thousand
you know
um mainly Punk and hardcore because
that's what I grew up on and um and I
and I'm encapsulating like a thousand
pieces of vinyl you guys I'm never gonna
touch them I'm never gonna play them if
I want to play it I'll just get the new
version you know yeah like the the first
editions the limited to 100s the test
presses you know like Beatles records if
you look at the top sales from vinyl or
selling one sold for a million like
Ringo Starr's White album sold for over
1.2 million wow and that needs to be
encapsulated that needs to be graded
that no one should be playing that
particular vinyl I should be protected
and celebrated yeah you know you got any
Gorilla Biscuits vinyl in there I have a
girl discus tattoo on my back
that's Epic Man
dead
nice dude I got I mean I got all like
Civ and Walters rifles and like they're
really close with those guys and
everything
dude Sam should have done the tattoo on
yourself I know I got it when I was 18.
you know right right dude that's Epic
Man you ever thought about coming out
with your own skateboard
like a sick deck yeah I never had one
dude I got a trick on uh did you oh yeah
I mean yeah I was surprised to see that
you had the the skate ring is sick yeah
I mean I used to skate I I need to get
back on
man abandoned I'm so so happy that you
jumped on there and like it's uh it's
it's skateboarding is the ultimate and
diminishing returns when you hit your
floor yeah exactly I'm just too afraid
to fall I've like last time I I had like
the knee pads I look like a complete
poster I got elbow pads I'm like wrist
guards helmet I look so like like a kook
you know but that's hilarious I was like
if I'm gonna get up here and I'm gonna
try to do a stall or do anything and if
I hurt myself I'm gonna regret it right
right maybe maybe we can get you uh
concierge Kia on Spirit if they're
listening
and they'll meet you at the gate
all right well dude thank you so much
man what an honor and uh damn in the
whoop group dude yeah okay and then I'm
in the Wood Group
that that's kind of gamified for me
because like
like how bummed do you get if your green
recovery Circle
if you don't have that blue
uh what do you call it
um strain
to meet the grease yeah if you come up
short does that just bum you out I mean
I'm coming up short a lot especially on
the road because I sleep so [__] [__]
on the road yeah like I'm barely like
you know the early morning flights in
the late nights it [__] my head up so
when I'm home
it's all recovery it's ice bass sauna
red light hyper Barrel when you get good
recovery then you need to get strained
yeah I know I know but I work out I try
to work out every day when I'm home too
what's your guys is HRV right now do you
know today I'll check
mine was 76 last I checked
uh
my HRV today is 63. yeah mine's really
bad one's 42 42. and that yeah it always
stays around there like it's like
there was a time when I was doing like
150 ages
on the calls that whoop they were like
we've never seen anybody do like this
before but like what were you doing that
got you 150 that's crazy you were
cycling and no sugar it says no no no
sugar sugar the sugar sugar is
everything yeah I'm a [__] devil
yesterday I was 91. whoa so what'd you
do yesterday oh my God that's so good
that's so funny
right now I was 39 right now and I need
to get one of those yeah 42. so 31 42
questions yeah well dude I'm in the whip
group what happened to this Dad a tear
but dude so much fun man thank you yeah
this was great oh I didn't even mention
that uh how I just barged into your uh
Instagram DM like just out of nowhere
and then you got right back to it you're
stable
yeah yeah I gotta do that like yeah I
love it man thank you and uh yeah that's
it all right man that was awesome
let me say it again I think that was at
least one of the greatest podcasts we've
ever recorded and you know I'm talking
to you my beautiful wonderful street
team I could not be more thrilled that
it is you guys who are aware of this
giveaway my man Vinnie he's right right
there
Vinnie with his prison pocket with his
his Harem of unbelievably hot chicks his
new verification check that he did not
pay for I mean dude God is shining on
Vinnie and I need you to follow him
we were just talking about it man like
we're sending somebody on an adventure
you know tell us your dreams tell us
like what's important so you know I
think I might do this more in the future
got to be a good got to be a good one so
follow Vinnie and get to it all right
man I love you my beautiful street team
I love Steve Aoki too yeah dude
and I'm in Australia
[Music]